so next round Christ
2001 so beautiful Catalan with black there
are certainly nicer things
but what can you
do, apparently later ne normalri
one h practically always runner D2 because the
world class also
plays that, these runners F4
variant has really become relatively rare
that you can get them although  It's
certainly not that bad. I
know it somehow more just from
hearing it.
Yes, I was just wondering if
that was an idea, but I'm here.
I can maybe make A5 here,
take it straight away and now
C5, I think you shouldn't forget
that
black is better developed here than
white
so that seems a bit
cramped no what knows what knows that
plays can you take advantage of it somehow B
C4 Queen
B5 well I can just take that one
yes it won't be bad
I guess now Dr  I think it's pretty strong in
C4, so now he has to
do something about it. Probably best to
take it out on
C5. It doesn't look like
black is still so big here. Wow, he really allows
that. I think I'm
brave, yes, then we'll do it
I think that C3 is already a strong threat,
so I don't allow
it, let's say it
like this
E4 C3 so that C2 means okay,
that's
H t I can still
play C3 so let's
see, I can't
take it here
right now, I could take B4
play
yes yes I don't know what he
wants to do here now to be honest
you have to get out of the number first
here with the
pawn
so the question can now be taken e.g.
on F4 I can also just take A3
no so speaking doesn't do it  a lot
against I think I insist on it x times
then he wants to play knight C5
or something like that again calculate knight F4
knight F4 bishop B7
h I'll get rid of it now
nonsense can't be bad under
any
circumstances
so
well now here he has to take knight
then hit
no so yes maybe he threatens to take it now
yes well I can of course also very
stupidly cover this one again yes the
C3 if he now plays knight D3
hangs
E4 it doesn't matter
he says bishop E4 bishop knight knight
simply B4
h h can't do that
have knight E4 knight
B4 also don't see any tactics here at the moment,
good then normal search
for reinforcement
time
warning so I hope I have calculated this
correctly here
you will see right away
my idea is now queen E4 and
then
C2
so knight moves hangs, but I'm threatening  just
take it now there's just a whole
lot of
white Tower D4 is also
possible, I don't know exactly, but
I can use it all here now,
but of course not so much anymore,
you'll have to
pull at some point, probably
something stronger would work too  Is that because
now it's proven itself? Yes,
no
idea. Well, it somehow corresponds to the
course, but
I don't think I really played it